la très grande majorité des trajets en
voiture aujourd'hui en ile de france
font moins de 7 kilomètres mois de 7 km
c'est à dire 20 minutes un quart d'heure
vingt minutes de vélo ou de lelo
électrique c'est en partant de ce
constat que la région ile de france avec
l'aide d'ile-de-france mobilité a décidé
de lancer son service de location de
vélos électriques longue durée veliko
vingt mille vélos en location longue
durée pour 20 euros par mois avec le
remboursement employeur eh bien on peut
découvrir le vélo électrique pendant six
mois
est ce que je viens d'annoncer c'est que
après ces six mois à partir de février
2020 la région qui veut être un puissant
réducteur d'inégalités sur tout son
territoire proposera pour chaque
francilien quelle que soit la ville où
il habite une aide de 500 euros à
l'achat une aide individuelle de 500
euros à l'achat de vélos électriques de
150 points de location sont mis en place
dans toute la région dont sept à saint
quentin en yvelines
la région souhaite donner l'accès à ce
mode de déplacement souple oh non
parisiens dont le territoire est plus
mal au nez vous avez évidemment le
moteur la batterie qui est sûr le cadre
qui est unique et qui est pour ce vélo
qui permet d'être branché directement si
vous habitez en rez-de-chaussée sur ce
côté latéral ou de la déloger et de la
prendre avec vous dans votre bureau ou à
votre domicile
une batterie d'une autonomie de 75 km
mais également un poste de pilotage où
loger son smartphone avec une prise usb
pour récupérer de l'autonomie 1500
utilisateurs se sont déjà inscrits
durant l'été et parmi eux quatre
chanceux on peut récupérer leur vélio
mercredi en septembre journée officielle
du lancement du service